another big piece of the user experience
our notifications notifications allow
you to communicate with the user and
they can take many different forms text
messages emails push notifications icons
vibrations banners and alerts you'll
need to think carefully about how often
you notify users and what forms those
notifications take since they contribute
to the overall user experience a graph
our matrix like this one can help you
think through the importance and urgency
of your notifications as I walk through
the upcoming examples you should think
about where notifications might fall on
this diagram in general you want to
avoid sending many messages that have
low importance and low urgency if you're
sending a lot of these types of messages
it can make your product feel spammy
keep in mind that the frequency for a
given notification may change over time
and this graph might look different for
different personas using the product you
should think about different
notifications for different personas as
you work on your product some might have
preferences for one notification over
others in general there are some key
qualities of notifications that you
should keep in mind for your users the
first one is control and it's the most
important thing that you want to give
users little big details as a website
that showcases a lot of Awesome user
experience when it comes to control
Foursquare and Apple gives users lots of
control through menus like these
the second is feedback other types of
notifications involve informing the user
about tasks that they are performing
this is really just about good design
and user experience the feedback
provided is dependent on the product and
by providing great feedback you can make
users feel like you are looking out for
them while making the product more
usable for example Twitter will try and
provide feedback if you send the same
tweet twice slack a messaging app also
provides great feedback to users it
provides a confirmation when sending a
message to a channel that has people in
different time zones
and Amazon provides feedback about
whether someone may have bought you an
item on your wish list all of these
notifications are related to feedback
loops for users to successfully complete
tasks the
customization it's a more subtle aspect
of notifications for your users
you might do this based on time task
location or some other attribute that's
tied to the user Facebook for example
shows a different part of the world to
users depending on the user's location
finally you can develop notifications
that lead users to form a habit of using
your product depending on the frequency
and any rewards you might give them you
can tap into what NIR I yell describes
as variable rewards github provides
variable rewards to its users by showing
a different octocat each time the user
has no new notifications tumblr sends
emails with playful text when a user
follow someone or when someone else
follows that user and coffee meets bagel
which is a dating application uses
digital currency to reward users for
tapping into the dating app each of
these qualities contributes to the user
experience and their perception of your
product